[Musique]
aujourd'hui je présentais le parrain un
film de Francis Ford Coppola de 1972
écrit par Mario Puzzo et adapté du livre
qu'il avait aussi lui-même écrit
évidemment au-delà d'un thème qu'on ne
présente plus et que musique que tout le
monde a entendu même sans avoir vu le
film
[Musique]
le parrain c'est
considéré comme souvent d'ailleurs
derrière cette zone comme le deuxième
meilleur film de tous les temps le
parrain suis le parcours de Michael
kornéon joué par un passino de tout
jeune qui au début du film ne veut
absolument rien avoir avec sa famille de
mafieux
menée par Don Corleone par un Marlon de
Bordeaux incroyable couvert de prothèse
méconnaissables ou le studio d'ailleurs
s'est battu contre Coppola ce qu'il ne
voulait pas d'un Brandeau qui était jugé
ingérable sur un plateau et copacité
battu pour dire il faut brado et
aujourd'hui on peut pas imaginer le film
120 brand dans ce rôle là et donc son
ascension dans dans cette mafia le film
a une histoire encombolex sur la une
série qui est sorti à pas longtemps il y
a offert sur le comment ce film est créé
mais la voiture du producteur avait été
avait été criblée de balle pour leur
faire peur il y a eu des menaces copola
raconte que son téléphone sonner parfois
en pleine nuit avec personne au bout du
film ou juste une respiration un film
rempli de mystères et de mythes en tout
cas autour la mafia à l'époque en tout
cas il y a des pressions pour que le mot
mafia Cosa Nostra n'apparaisse pas dans
le film et dans le scénario donc il
avait été retiré c'est un film tellement
intemporel et c'est quand même le film
qui a lancé tous les films sur la mafia
et sur le crime aujourd'hui on a aucun
film aujourd'hui sur cette thématique là
qui existerait sans le parrain tous les
codes sont là que soit l'atmosphère que
ce soit les codes la mafia en costume
cravate tout ça c'est le parrain qu'il a
montré en premier et ce sont des images
qui sont tellement dans l'imaginaire
collectif qu'on ne peut pas imaginer
aujourd'hui un film de gangster sans
penser aux parents c'est un film long il
faut s'accrocher sentiment différente de
ce qu'on ferait aujourd'hui en terme de
rythme il y a une pression de la mise en
scène il y a pas un plan qui est pas là
où il devrait être mais surtout voilà
Pacino dans dans peut-être le rôle de sa
vie donc un film à voir le parrain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]